Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn his time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday.
Fucking June 27th June.
What stuff?
What happened to this month?
My goodness.
Where's it go?
And you know what?
I think July 18th.
That's my hat.
Oh fuck.
July teeth.
I think we'll be wrapped.
We'll be done with the writing of the 10 episodes ofF is for family.
Then all we got to do is look at the drawings and edit them for the next fucking
10 months.
Ooh.
But the heavy lifting will be out of the way.
Um,
would you guys like to know on an animated show works well?
You sit in a room and you'd come up with fucking whatever.
Yeah.
You have figured out how the whole season's going to go.
Then you fucking write it and then it changes like 50 fucking times.
You rewrite,
you rewrite,
you rewrite your record.
You're right.
Boy,
you do table reads,
you do all this fucking shit.
Then once you get all of that done,
what starts coming in as the animatics,
which is basically the rough drawings of a,
of the shit,
you know that you recorded and then you say,
ah,
you know,
why is he standing next to that chair is she'd be over in the kitchen.
You got to do all of that shit is he's not moving enough,
having take his glasses off day or a heaven to fucking be.
You got to do all of that and then they fucking draw it and then you look at it
and then it still might not be funny.
And then you gotta be like,
all right is what we wrote.
Not Funny or is the way it's executed here?
Not fighting that.
That's why it takes so fucking long in case you're wondering,
cause you're like,
well shit,
you record it.
I mean you wrote them.
Why don't they just take out some magic maracas and fucking put him on a piece
of paper and then somebody stands there and they flip through it like they used
to in the old days they used to do,
they'd have somebody,
a the village idiot go up on stage with a giant fucking notebook and he'd sit
there going,
just going through the thing.
And people would sit there and they enjoy it.
And if the guy screwed up,
they uh,
they shot him because everybody had guns back then.
Lisa,
I the way it was in America,
um,
speaking of of America,
what's going on in Ireland,
I decided I was going to start looking to see what the fuck is going on in these
countries.
So I'm going to be going to a evidentaly mot know Neil Martin O'Neill,
the Republic of Ireland,
Martin O'neill there,
there,
bill Belicheck.
He's fucking pissed because Ireland just lost a French.
It's some gay boy.
You're not allowed to pick the ball up with the hands for whatever fucking
reason.
You know,
you'd figure if you're only allowed to use your feet or your hands,
or let's say you use your fucking hands.
I mean,
there's no style of fighting where you just use your feet,
right?
Maybe Tae Kwan Doe,
but they don't,
you know,
if you fucking come at them,
they're still going to punch you in the nose,
right.
I just don't understand it.
I'm fucking with you.
It's actually,
it's a beautiful game.
I,
I went in to get my head fucking shaved the other day.
Now what?
To this blob of shop or a real barber shop.
One where you walk in and there's fucking men in there.
Right?
Rubbing the hairy chest.
And I'm kidding.
There's men in there and you just fucking go,
Eddie.
You sit down until it's your fucking turn.
Unlike these fucking God damn hipster fucking thinks.
What did they got the little fucking,
what do you call that barbershop little swirl thing that goes around to me that
says I can just walk in,
right?
And then you walk in,
there's nobody here.
Can you shake my head?
Oh,
do you have an appointment?
Dude,
look at me.
How long is it going to fucking take?
You don't want to make an extra fucking 20 bucks,
Huh?
You down?
I can go fuck yourself.
You know,
you fucking 28th president of the United States fucking haircut.
Who is that by the way?
Who was the 28th president?
Nobody ever talks about the 28th presence.
Let's look it up.
Uh,
28 president.
If I,
if I had to guess,
I'm going to say Grover Cleveland.
Uh,
28th,
President Calvin Coolidge.
Oh,
ah,
oh,
the content self.
Woodrow Wilson,
who signed the fucking Federal Reserve Act and a,
and we're all still paying for it today.
You know,
what's a good one to look up Woodrow Wilson's letter of regret?
What are the fucking odds I would've said that sent me down this conspiracy
theory.
Woodrow Wilson Letter of regret.
All right,
where is it?
Where is it?
Did Wilson,
did Woodrow Wilson regret handing America
to the Federal Reserve?
Woodrow Wilson,
after creating the Federal Reserve,
said,
uh,
let's see.
Here we go.
I have unwittingly ruined my country.
I didn't know how to pronounce that word,
so maybe he didn't.
All right.
This is what he wrote.
I am a most unhappy man.
I have unwittingly,
unwittingly ruined my country.
A great industrial nation is controlled by its system of credit.
Our system of credit is concentrated.
See,
they always got to write it.
So sophisticated,
subsist sophisticatedly.
I can't even understand what the fuck they're talking about.
Like that thing.
Dwight d Eisenhower,
when he gives that speech about the industrial military complex,
I watch that over and over again.
I have no fucking idea what he's talking about.
Even if it's explained to me before I watched the speech and by the end of it I,
I don't understand it and I feel like he said it that way either because he was
so fucking smart.
He couldn't relate to the common man,
which I don't understand because he had all those soldiers or he said it that
way because he had to say it in a way that he wouldn't get off.
Right.
I don't fucking know him.
Anyways,
he said the growth of the nation,
therefore,
and all our activities are in the hands of a few men.
This is a president.
A former president wrote this.
Okay.
So I don't want to hear any guys saying,
oh,
conspiracy theory,
go fuck yourself.
It's just like when I told you that the NBA was fixed and then there was the mob
dup ref,
and you guys all tried to wiggle out of it.
And what did they say?
Oh yeah,
there was just one of them.
Oh yeah.
What's that?
There was just one of them.
All right.
We have to come to,
we have come to be one of the worst,
ruled,
one of the most completely controlled and dominated governance governments in
the civilized world loan longer a government by free opinion.
No longer a government by conviction and the vote of the majority,
but a government by the opinion and duress of a small group of dominant men.
Oh,
there you go.
He still didn't quite fucking say what he did.
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Uh,
God,
they got,
they got fucking,
you know what they did?
Woodrow,
they put woody from cheers,
their version of chairs or their version of woody from fucking chairs.
They put them in the office.
Well,
what am I even talking about right now?
I didn't want to talk about this.
I was talking about soccer.
How the fuck do I go from soccer to that?
So anyways,
it's Martin O'Neill who I would not fuck with some of it.
An Irish brogue in those fucking glasses.
You're not,
you know,
just somehow tea shop you to the throat.
Um,
he said they got the short end short straw when they played France for whatever
fucking reason.
I never even finished the story.
So I wanted to get my fucking head shaved.
And a,
they had that European champion was a championship,
was on the highlights,
the whole fucking,
the everybody in there was into the game.
So I automatically got into it.
So I hope you guys know I'm just fucking with you when it comes to that.
It's just that when the world loves something,
as a comedian,
it's just so easy to make fun of it and to get the feedback that you want,
which is totally people losing their minds typing at you in all capital letters.
It's just fun.
Um,
so anyways,
for some reason France got an extra three days to rest.
They're tired.
Legs in there,
swollen feet before they got to play the little footie game again in Ireland.
Didn't like it.
You know what's funny?
The Guy,
the guy like trashes them and says,
uh,
you know,
they got fucked over three days as an incredible amount of time.
A one side could have as an advantage over another blahblahblahblahblah that
said,
France,
France are really,
really fine team and good luck to them in the tournament.
I love that shit.
After you fucking trash them.
It was completely unfair.
Go Fuck Yourself.
But I haven't said that you got a hell of a team there.
Hawaii.
Chico.
Could she add?
Yeah.
Meaty.
All right.
Irish news headlines March going on an island.
Roy Foster Britain cosigned a margins by the stupid party.
I don't know what that means.
Mary Robinson is,
that's not a real name.
Mary Robinson is that an alias?
Brexit could have a domino effect.
What the fuck is Brexit?
Isn't this shit Trump got in trouble for,
that's what I loved about Trump this week when he fucking went to Scotland and
he goes,
just like Scotland,
we're going to take our country back.
Cause I guess Scotland was voting about whether they still want it to be a part
of the European Union and a Scotland overwhelmingly agreed to stay part of it.
Evidently,
I dunno.
And Trump went there and didn't know it and I was reading like what everyone was
saying and it was,
you know,
trash and Donald Trump.
And it was so similar to what people write to me every week.
John Salley isn't dead.
You fucking moron.
I said the wrong name.
I didn't mean John.
Sally,
you know what?
What do,
what do you want from me?
All right.
A former president,
president or what?
Mary Robinson.
Okay.
She was president of Ireland.
You know what?
She's a lovely lady.
I'd vote for her.
Where the fuck was she president?
Former president.
Mary Robinson has said that young people in the UK must feel very let down by
the outcome of the Brexit Brexit model,
the referendum,
and she appealed to the EU to remember its core values.
What other vague shit that she say,
Jesus Christ,
can you help out or an American here,
what the fuck's going on over there?
A crisis.
There's some bullshit.
I have to know when I go over there
some sort of referendum.
Should the United Kingdom remain a member of the European Union or leave the
European Union?
What's going on with the European Union?
The EU?
What happened?
You guys formed a super group,
but now all the egos are getting in the way.
What happened?
How Greece is fucking economy went down and all of a sudden it's fucking with
you guys.
You never do that.
Never join a fucking group.
Take it from a complete loner who does stand up,
right?
You don't join a group.
You know what I mean?
You use a group.
Okay,
what do you guys do?
Oh yeah,
you cater parties.
All right,
I'm having a party.
I don't want to join your party operation.
I'd like you to come over here and a tie,
some balloons to some fucking lampposts.
Could you do that and how much would that cost and here's your check and get out
of my life.
That's how you do it.
Why the fuck would you agree?
It's actually amazing that they got it done.
You don't want,
I mean,
considering all the fucking wars they've had over the years,
you know,
fascism,
communism,
fucking,
whatever the fuck we're called.
I don't know what the fuck we are.
Hmm?
How the fuck did they do all that know?
Why did they do all that?
That just all comes down to bankers.
What was wrong with having the pound and then the fucking Ireland had the
Shillay Lee,
right?
What they have in Sweden,
I don't know what the fuck they had.
Some sort of thing.
A little idea of design the way little sphincter.
I don't fucking know.
I don't understand why everybody has to get in bed with everybody else is going
to be better.
It's going to create more jobs.
No,
it isn't.
It's just going to make the people at the top make more fucking money.
It's just like,
you know,
can we have more people to fucking the ass?
Can we have of your people one of four we would've.
He combined all the people,
right?
We fucking microchip them.
We phased out fucking money.
What if we did that right?
And now,
yeah,
everything's on your little microchip here,
right?
People getting mugged in the future,
it's going to be fucking hilarious.
It's going to be some fucking nerdy kid getting dragged in by a football player
and you're going to grab a bunch of Dr Peppers and some fucking Sag nut bars,
and then they're going to grab the nerds wrist and fucking just keep swiping it,
making them pay for all his shit,
right?
If you're fucking rich,
you're going to,
you can't even go out of the fucking house.
Someone's going to grab you and take you to a Lexus dealership.
It's of a fucking
grabbed the guy just fucking,
just start scanning of,
oh,
that'd be great.
You know,
it's not going to happen.
They're going to have,
you're gonna have like 50,
oh my God,
this is,
this is going to be some shit going down.
If you get,
if you're going to have a microchip in your fucking body that has every fucking
cent you ever earned that you didn't blow on fucking bud lights and hookers,
you know,
doesn't that make you like,
what's going to stop somebody from just coming up and just sucker punching you
and then carving your fucking microchip out of your arm?
Right.
And then it's like they got an extra life and then they just have this fucking
thing and they just start running around with tweezers,
just scan and a bunch of shit.
Why wouldn't they just,
you know what they're gonna do?
They'll fucking chop your arm off,
right.
And then fucking hide your body.
Okay.
You know,
like they used to do that,
like allegedly the,
uh,
the westies they chopped some guy's arm off and then they would go around
committing murders and then they'd take the arm out of the fridge and they'd put
the fingerprints on the gun and then they just put the arm back in the fridge.
It's if you get past the fucking humanity,
you know,
it's really brilliant and slash borderline fucking hilarious.
Um,
manifest.
Those guys could tell a story.
Jesus Christ,
you know the shit they did horrible shit.
But Jesus,
yeah,
I have to be a funny bastard on some fucking level.
I know you're out of your mind,
but there is something fucking hilarious about that,
you know?
And then the cops that,
you know,
when they were drinking the cops that just select,
that's fucking guys struck again.
You know,
they will laugh and go,
dude,
you realize we're inventing a serial killer.
And they'd all be sitting there laughing their balls off.
And then at some point the laughter would die down is that they then realize
like,
wait a minute,
where we're kind of serial killers while we're all doing it.
It's a group effort.
It's not like it's one person.
So yeah,
you know,
whatever order.
Another Jamison.
Um,
anyways,
I have no fucking idea what I'm talking about and I have no idea what's going on
in the world and I evidently I need to learn it.
I need to learn it before,
you know,
I go to Scotland,
started handing up.
Fuck those signs.
You know,
Trump is a cunt.
I just,
all of that Shit,
Donald Trump is fucking,
he's back to being fucking hilarious again to me because I know he's not going
to win.
He's not going to win.
The whole world can fucking relax.
Everybody knows Hillary's getting in.
Okay.
And what's funny is everybody's going to relax,
relax.
Like I'll thank God we dodged that fucking bullet.
Like Hillary isn't a fucking bankers wet dream coming down like a fucking
freight train.
Um,
now Jesus,
she better not get elected.
I'm getting a fucking audit.
Do you want a times I've trashed her.
Oh my God.
Oh God,
that fucking,
oh,
some of the shit I want to say.
I can't fucking say it because in this day and age you just,
you just cannot say that.
You understand why a certain person did what he did.
Um,
age is Christ just coming home to that fucking air raid siren every fuck he can
eat.
Least fucking,
you know,
doll yourself up a little bit.
Jesus Christ with the fucking the paper chase.
Look over here.
I mean,
what,
what was the guy's supposed to do?
I'm just kidding.
Bill Clinton would fuck a hole in a tree
and he would do it with his fucking pants down with the fucking secret service
standing with their backs to him like five feet away.
They could literally filling,
don't feel the wind of his hips,
his,
he was pumping the tree guys at animal day in and fucking day out.
That guy is a fucking animal.
God bless.
You know what?
God bless him.
You know,
it's just how he's wired.
Did you guys ever see that episode of cheaters?
Remember that show they'd catch people cheating,
right.
And that lady cut the fuck.
Can anybody find this clip from me?
This Liz Lady,
um,
southern Belle,
she catches her fucking redneck guy stepping out on it,
right?
And this fucking guy,
she,
you know,
he was supposed to be embarrassed,
but he was hammered,
cheesy,
like,
oh my God,
if I can see shit,
I could cheat,
do this.
And she's,
you know,
slapping.
I had a fucking to do this.
And he goes,
well honey,
did it ever dawn on you that maybe just maybe I was tired of fucking you and I
wanted to fuck someone else.
And he said it.
The wiz delivery of that epic line was just,
it was like,
he was saying like,
like hello.
You know,
fucking get your shit together.
The fucking answers right here.
Like he said,
it was such,
he was putting it on her.
It was,
it was one of the,
one of the,
one of the more amazing things I've seen a human being doing that situation,
you know what I mean?
Anyways,
let me get back to the fucking,
what's going on here in Scotland?
What's going on here.
Oh,
by the way,
uh,
so Belgium has been added.
Germany has been added though.
You know I'm making,
I think that paying me like with a couple of steins of beer,
which I don't give a fuck.
I just want to go over there.
I want to,
I'm that close.
You know I'm going to do Germany,
some weird fucking town I never heard of and then I'm driving over to Belgium
and I'm not doing
what the,
I was a fucking capital of Brussels.
I don't fuck with it.
No,
it is Brussels.
Right?
A Belgium.
Brussels,
right.
Sorry,
I'm doing like 20 things here.
I just realized I never found out.
Who the Fuck Mary Rob's where?
Jesus Christ.
She must've been a great,
she looks honest as the fucking days long.
Manny.
Robyn said for president.
Oh yeah.
Tell you she's cute as a button,
but I wouldn't want to cross hairs.
That fucking shit.
Any field.
Is that what you guys said over there?
What the fuck is his Shalala bill?
You don't know.
All right.
Mary Robinson.
Matt
may remain re.
Oh Jesus.
That's an unfortunate fucking picture.
Jesus Christ.
Has she ever used conditioner in our life?
Her fucking hair.
It looks like the Hollywood hills.
Right before they catch on fire.
Did the Santa Ana winds come out of her fucking hairdryer?
Oh,
I thought she was dead.
She's not dead.
And she
okay.
In office from 1969 to 1989 she's 72 years old.
She's got three k.
Wait a minute.
Where Mary Theresa?
Same.
Hey,
we have here Howard eightish born at 20 fashion at made 1844 he and [inaudible]
into that.
I don't have time to read all of this presidency.
Okay.
All right.
Open the fucking linky account.
Robinson was inaugurated as the seventh president of Ireland.
Well,
how many fucking dumb alone do you stay in office?
Seven presidents since caveman days.
Uh,
she proved a remarkably popular president earning the praise of Brian Lenahan
himself.
Well,
shit,
if Brian says it well then fuck.
You know,
before his death,
five years later,
sorry,
Brian and the Lenahan film,
uh,
said that she was a better president than he ever could have been.
Oh,
that was the guy that went after.
Yeah.
Cat Elekta is fucking.
Hi.
All right.
I'm Saturday.
She was great.
That was every fucking I and over there,
cause she took an office that had a reputation as being little more than a
retirement position for a prominent politician and breathed new life into the
room.
How is that a retirement position?
You're president of Ireland?
Yeah.
Oh God.
I got some questions when I get over there.
Yeah,
Brian fucking lend a hand.
Let's see what Brian Linehan look like.
Yes,
said,
get oldies.
You really want to see what people look like to figure out why they died.
Brian Linehan,
Brian Linehan.
Let's see what it looks like.
Let's see.
The old gimme,
the
Ah,
you fucking in shape can't come on,
man.
You supposed to have the heart attack face.
Oh,
that's not the guy.
Cleo,
did you just fart?
Okay.
I said,
well hang on a second.
What the fuck is,
what the fuck is the guy's name?
Brian Linehan.
He died five years.
Actually,
the guy just looked up with some Canada.
I got,
I still have a chance here that this guy was a,
Oh my God.
Do I have to hit fucking pause to find this again.
All right.
Presidency,
Brian Linehan.
Alright,
there it is.
Brian Linehan.
Come on.
You can't Ireland a or didn't or he [inaudible].
Okay,
there we go.
Let's see what this fucking did.
Son of a bitch.
Oh,
there it is.
Oh yeah,
that's a heart attack face.
If I ever saw,
I'm saying heart attack,
I'm going heart attack.
He died on my birthday was an Irish and a barrister.
What the fuck is that?
Does that mean he sings while he tends bar,
uh,
death?
Just get the death died.
Okay.
He died then.
Oh God.
There's been an upbeat disease.
Come on.
I say heart attack,
heart attack.
Nice and quick.
Pancreatic cancer.
50 to fuck.
I'm to 48.
Jesus Christ or his skin off this fucking subject.
Uh,
Micah Dolan's just to the linear hand family.
Anyways,
it's such a fucking,
it's the fucking worst.
I got a buddy of mine,
I,
this is something too,
I'm going to be doing a sh a benefit coming up.
I just have to figure out how to put it together.
Uh,
I got a really good friend of mine.
His wife just got cancer for the second time and they get fucking buried in
bills.
So,
um,
I'm going to put together a show out here in La and uh,
you know all the proceeds are going to go to that and that's fucking sad.
All right.
I'm sorry.
I thought it was gonna be selling for heart attacks.
Fucking funny.
Right?
You just stand in the hey bill,
you want another reg,
you know actually gloss and just
whenever you drop dead,
people laugh at first cause they think you fucking around.
Like wow man,
he really committed to that fucking face plant.
Okay,
well right now all of a sudden you just laying them all right,
I'm sorry.
Oh last week.
You know I recommend that you guys go to the all things comedy website,
you know if all these great podcasts and videos and all this shit.
So of course these fucking millennials,
they get there and they just stare at it.
They're fucking overwhelmed.
So they're like,
oh could you please tell me who Coppola podcasts that you arc the movie I could
look at.
Cause I can't do anything.
Most sale.
All right.
Egg
last week already.
HSA fear from the skeptic tank podcast did a podcast with comedian.
Uh,
I'm going to butcher this name.
Hormoze.
Rashidi that's how I'm saying it about the Middle East.
It's hilarious and informative.
Uh,
this dude was born in Iran.
So rather than listening to bill O'Reilly talk about the Middle East,
even though he's never fucking been there are fucking Wolf fucking blends.
All these talking heads with their books,
you know,
and their lines of suits right from the bill.
O'Reilly collection from theW is a wolf blitzer tie,
right?
Whatever the fuck it is that they do to get the XD or extra whore money,
you know,
who we think has a better walk in closet.
Bill O'reilly,
a Wolf Blitzer,
you know though,
they're fucking shiny loafers,
you know,
sent.
Just so you know,
all their suits all lined up,
their pocket squares and all of that shit.
You know what I mean?
You fucking take you downstairs to the wine cellar and show you these bottles of
wine.
They'd fucking hundreds of years old.
You see that?
Look at that.
Okay.
Then I get this for lying every day on television and then amazing.
Come on.
He do coke.
You want to do some coke?
All right.
Just,
it was down here.
I just figured I'd ask you.
You know,
the wife does.
Wife's got a rule,
no coke on the fucking main floor.
Um,
anyways,
I'll speak to my wife.
Oh,
let me tell me my wife.
It's a rough one.
You know.
Um,
I got this new thing that I,
that I'm into,
man.
And uh,
you'd think it wouldn't be a big deal.
I like,
uh,
I like fucking tennis and golf shirts.
I like them.
They're comfortable,
they're breathable.
It's a college shirt.
People let you into restaurants when you wear them and she fucking hates them.
I liked the izod tennis wear.
So today I'm walking out of the house to go meet a buddy of mine and I got one
of those on and I got these fucking,
uh,
I got these Phil Mickelson shorts,
whatever the fuck they are,
just,
they're just black shorts or whatever.
So as I'm walking out,
I guy Niihau CLS,
she goes,
all right,
she goes until tiger woods.
I said,
what's up?
She fucking hates how I dress.
And this is one of these things where you know,
as much as you want to remain your own person,
when you're in a relationship,
when you've,
the person you fucking says you're not,
you don't look good,
it affects you.
But there's some I have,
this is how comfortable these fucking shirts are.
I don't think I give a shit.
I think for the first time ever,
I don't care that my wife doesn't approve of what the fuck I'm wearing.
They had that fucking comfortable.
You never have to iron them.
They're great.
They're fucking great.
So I was,
uh,
I was at the mall there.
Um,
I really should fucking,
this is just like free advertising for all these fucking people.
Um,
what's the shit that the,
uh,
the honor roll student wears?
What's it called?
Bardot and body armor.
Yeah.
We're not taking that shit.
Know her house clothes,
whatever was over the top fucking sports thing.
Armor wear underarm,
whatever the fuck it is.
You know what it is?
Defense shields some fucking space odyssey shit.
You know the fucking thing,
the thing that Steph curry wears
under Armour,
under Armour.
That's what it is under arms.
Do you own rent bill?
A under Armour,
right?
They got some fucking,
they got some great clothes.
So I,
I knew,
I knew she didn't like that shit cause I said to her for my birthday,
I go,
I don't,
I don't fucking either.
You know what I would love to the summer,
the summer's here
and the tab is Rad for where?
In some golf clothes.
Um,
so I told her that,
uh,
you know,
I told her,
just give me a couple of those shirts,
two pairs of shorts and I'll be fine.
I'll be good.
She's like,
Oh yeah.
And usually she such into fashion,
she gets excited when I tell her the clothes and you know,
my fucking birthday comes along and I got to tell you,
there was not a hint of any of that shit.
So I called her on it like a couple of days ago.
I said,
hey,
you know,
uh,
I noticed,
you know,
I asked you for those things.
They're not expensive.
You are right there.
And it was an easy,
it was an easy gift to get me to pad,
you know,
make it look like he actually spent time shopping,
which is why I always go and I get her lists of workout clothes.
That's always the next of fee yet.
Go right there,
Fred.
Do you give him a couple more and it looks like you give a shit,
you know more than you.
Yeah.
Not saying you don't give a shit,
but who the fuck wants to shop?
Nobody.
All right.
I don't want to do it,
therefore nobody wants to do it.
That's how,
that's my worldview.
Okay.
I'm really starting to learn from Trump.
If I feel something,
then everybody else also feels it.
And if they don't,
then we should ram it down their throats.
And somewhere in there we take their coats.
Is,
isn't not how it works.
Um,
have you ever seen a guy like less toughen your life talk so fucking tough.
Like,
I dunno,
I don't understand why he,
he's mistaking having money with actually being physically intimidating,
um,
with that stupid scowl on his face.
I don't know if like Gene Simmons had a brother that didn't make it,
that wasn't in a band.
That's what he looks like.
He looks like he's related to Gene Simmons and he resents Jean's success.
Um,
anyways,
plowing ahead here.
So my wife fucking hates that shit and I called her on it.
I was just going like,
you,
you didn't like that stuff,
did you?
And she just fucking started smiling and looking down at her food.
And,
um,
I was over there today and I,
I was going to stop and go in and buy some and uh,
I didn't.
And the only reason why I didn't is because it's Sunday and it's a mall.
And um,
that's just like,
I dunno,
I don't know what it is.
I don't know what it is about the and malls now.
I understand kids go in there,
teenagers going there because then you'll run into other teenagers and you
fucking go like,
okay,
will you go out with me?
Right.
That shit,
at least that's what we did when we were of that age.
But like parents,
like I just don't understand what,
why would you go there?
Especially if you get like some little kid and you got to fucking push him
around and that Goddamn stroller trying to weave in and out of all those people,
I just can't imagine the fucking misery of that.
You know?
That's definitely a Wifi idea.
You know,
we should go to the mall today.
I know that I don't want to go to the mall.
You know,
I have all these theories as to why men die before women.
And uh,
you know what it is.
Women have to include you in their shitty day.
You know,
I fucking,
um,
this is my sister in law's birthday this weekend,
right?
So we ended up going to a,
uh,
to a movie.
I was all excited and we saw,
what did we see?
We saw a independence day.
Whew.
It was actually so bad.
It was good.
We actually ended up having a great time and I don't want to ruin the movie,
but like the fact that the white guide precedent has to come back,
you know,
and get shit done is a little fucked up.
You know,
Hollywood tries to be liberal,
you know,
they'll have a chick president,
they'll have a black guy flying a fucking jet and all that type of shit.
But at the end of the day they bring back the old founding father to come in and
save the day.
Anyway.
So I had a great time doing that.
Right.
So the next night,
you know,
my wife's going to go meet some friends.
I think it was actually,
it was a continuation of the birthday celebration and I was actually tired so I
wasn't going to go.
So,
um,
I was just like,
you know what,
I'm going to hang in.
Um,
I have a ton of shit to do cause you know,
I sit in a writer's room all fucking day.
She goes,
fine,
cool.
I'm like,
great,
this is perfect.
I'll get a bunch of shit done and blah,
blah,
Blah and all that type of stuff.
So right around the time it's time for her to go right and I'm about ready to
have a beer or anything thing and she just goes,
can you try me over?
She didn't say it like that,
but that's what she probably says,
honey,
can you drive me over?
But like,
cause I didn't want to do it.
That's what it sounded like.
And I was just like,
you can't,
well why don't you drive yourself over?
And she just like
me and so I go full fucking Uber.
She's like,
what?
I want me,
you know?
And I just went like,
why can't you know I'm home?
Why do you got to dream?
You're the one who's going across fucking town.
You're going across town.
Why do I got to go across town to,
you know why you don't fucking know why.
At the end of the day,
they,
if they have something shitty to do,
they can't do a,
can't fucking do it on their own.
Somehow you gotta be.
That's like when they have a fucking kid now they dragged the husband in there.
What the fuck is he doing in there?
He's not a doctor.
Do you know?
I know a guy went in there and you fucking saw what was going on.
He passed out.
Now they've got two patients.
The fuck is that,
you know.
Well,
if I have to go through the,
well fuck it.
Talk to God.
Talk to God for once.
For once.
The shit ran your way and now I got to go in there too so you can hold my
fucking hand and break my God damn finger.
That's fucking,
that is the defect that fucking men gave into that shit that you got to fucking
be in there.
Is that if you were getting fucking gallbladder surgery,
what I be standing in their holding your fucking hand.
I Dunno,
but I guess if fucking him gave him gallbladders I,
I,
I don't know that gallbladder,
kidney stones is some shit.
I guess you'd have to be.
That's the dumbest shit in the fucking,
it's the stupidest shit ever.
My wife has talked,
if we have every kid,
you're going to go in there.
I was like,
no,
she got so fucking mad at me over a hypothetical child.
If I was smarter,
I just would assume I'm getting smarter though.
I,
if I was smarter,
smart married guys go,
well absolutely I'll blue at out.
We buy it at.
That was your way to put the baby in me.
I would fucking shit it out my ass.
Daddy.
Think for you sweetheart.
Right?
Oh,
I'm getting heated here.
Right.
I'm getting smarter though as a married man.
Cause I'll tell you this right now.
The other one,
we went to go see the movie I got there first.
Okay.
And uh,
I got there,
it was seven o'clock show.
I got there at like six 30 and I was like,
fuck,
you know,
I get time.
Maybe I'll you it as a place to get a sandwich.
I didn't want to eat movie food,
so I got to rap and then they fucking had a beer too.
And by the way,
I,
every fucking time I ordered this is beer from Mexico.
It fucking sucks.
I'm not saying all their beers stinks,
but I got to tell you.
Hello.
Well,
let me tell you that fucking bear steaks.
I'm going to get you the name of this right fucking,
it's gonna be a reverse commercial.
There it is.
Okay.
The fuck is that shit called Modelo.
Hang on a second.
I think that's what it's called.
It is the fucking most bitter hoppy fucking,
it's like a job trying to get the thing down,
but it was still a beer.
So at the end of the day,
it's not all bad.
So I'm sipping this beer.
I'm having this sandwich.
I got plenty of time to eat it up.
Fucking relaxed.
My wife,
the lovely Nia,
she texted me,
she goes,
Hey,
I'm almost,
and I own like a dope.
I started to text,
Hey,
I'm already here.
I mean I'm having a sandwich and a beer.
Okay,
now this is the deal for all you youngsters out there.
One of the things women hate the most is when the guy is having fun without
them.
All right?
So any fucking time you're having a good time and they're not there,
you got it.
How has it gone?
Hey,
you know,
it's kind of crowded.
You always say it sucks.
Okay?
If you're having a good time,
then Anthea,
you're gonna have to fucking deal with that shit,
right?
This is the thing my wife is,
is as cool as it gets.
All right?
And I still have to go through this shit.
So I almost fucking texted her.
I'm sitting here having a wrap and join a fucking beer.
Blahblahblahblahblah and then,
you know what I was like,
what the fuck am I doing
if I say this,
she's going to then say,
can you get me one or she's going to tell me to go over and go get the fucking
tickets.
She's going to give me a job.
There's no fucking way she's going to allow me to just sit here and relax and
enjoy this sandwich in this beer that I fuck.
I've worked all fucking day.
When am I a fucking asshole?
So I just erased all of it.
And rather than saying all of that,
you know,
I'm on my way over here.
Oh,
I'm sitting here having a sandwich and a beer.
I erased all of that and I just wrote,
okay,
send,
that was it.
I didn't say I was there.
I didn't say I wasn't there.
And I sat there and I enjoyed it even though that beer was not my favorite.
And then,
um,
I ended up walking over and,
uh,
I ran into my sister in law and then I,
and then look at dope.
I texted my wife going,
yeah,
I'm just,
uh,
you know,
I'm here with your sister a lot,
blah,
blah.
And then she immediately texts back,
okay,
buy the tickets.
I immediately fucking is a job for you.
Here's a fucking job,
you know?
And she always goes,
well,
I ain't actually,
he's trying to streamline our life.
No,
you're not.
You treating me like your fucking assistant.
Um,
37 minutes.
Holy Fuck,
what am I doing here?
So that's one for you.
Okay.
This is what you kiss some you tell him you love him,
you tell him that beautiful every fucking day.
But I tell you this,
okay,
when you're having a good time and they're not there,
you never ever tell him you're having a good time.
No fucking pictures,
none of that shit.
Cause they will sit there and they'll either,
they'll,
you'll,
you'll sit there,
you'll be that guy.
You know that guy on the phone,
the while everybody's having a good time.
The guy in the corner,
he's on the phone talking to his girl.
Why is he talking to his girl?
Cause he told her he was having fun.
Stupid,
stupid,
stupid.
It's your fucking head in the game.
All right.
By the way,
the Australian Austrian Grand Prix is coming up this Sunday.
All right.
Cause I'm going fucking nuts right now.
No Hoop,
no hockey,
no football.
It's driving me fucking crazy.
And the fucking goddamn Dodgers struck up some fucking deal with,
I don't know who,
I don't know where that games are.
I don't even know if they fucking exist anymore.
I can never watch a Dodgers game sucks.
All right.
So anyways,
here we go.
Dollar Shave club,
everybody.
Oh Jesus,
here we go.
MMM.
All right,
everybody.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing razors right to your door for a third of
the price of what the greedy razor corporations charge.
That means when you joined dollar Shave Club,
you can afford to shave with a fresh blade anytime you want,
which feels fantastic.
All right,
get a first class shave whenever you use the executive blade and that's without
even hurting your wallet.
And whenever you use that,
you gotta be sure to use [inaudible].
Uh,
the blade is gently,
just gently glides across your skin for the smoothest shave ever.
Shave butter isn't your average shave cream.
It's a unique conditioning formula with high quality natural ingredients,
leaving your skin feeling unbelievably soft and smooth.
Now's a great time to join dollar shave club.
A new rent members who buy a tube of shave butter,
Dr Carver's shave butter.
Um,
get a month of the executive razor for free.
Take advantage of this special offer today.
It's available by going to dollar shave club.com/burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/bar high dollar shave club.com/ [inaudible] all
right,
here's a new appetizer,
uh,
Fran Bridge,
frame bridge.
All right.
Is that any seat frame,
frame bridge Cambridge is Cra em,
I'm gonna say frame bridge.
They sell frames.
Frame Bridge,
Fran Bridge,
uh,
got empty walls and you've got something special you want to frame but you never
do it because it takes too long.
It costs too much money.
Remember when cameras weren't part of your phone?
Uh,
the way we take pictures has changed,
but the way we frame them hazard until now.
Uh,
please mention the falling talking points.
I'm going to mention all of them.
Frame Bridge.
Oh,
now it's spelled with the,
so it is frame,
bridge frame,
bridge.com.
Okay.
Is the easy way to frame the things you love from the treasure trove of photos
on your phone to posters and at work.
Frame Bridge makes it easy and affordable.
Just go to frame bridge,
Dodd calm dude and pick out the frame you want or let their designers help you
choose.
You can even preview your item in any frame slash style,
any frame style,
sorry.
They'll send an you a prepaid package to ship your items safely.
Or you can simply upload a picture to frame bridge site or APP.
You can even upload a picture directly from the Instagram.
I'm fucking easy.
Is that the expert team?
Frame Bridge.
We'll custom frame your items in days,
not weeks or months in days,
and deliver your finished piece directly to your door.
Ready to hang in style called frame bridge.
The genius site that makes custom framing easy frame bridge offers a happiness
guarantee.
Their team gives each item personal care and attention because meeting your
expectation is as important as meeting their own.
Instead of hundreds of dual,
I'll lists you'd paid at a framing store.
Their prices start at just 39 bucks and all shipping is free.
All right,
right now you go to frame bridge.com f,
r a,
g e,
frame and bridge frame,
bridge.com and use Promo Code Burr,
and you'll save an additional 15% off your first order.
Just go to [inaudible] dot com Promo Code Bar frame,
bridge.com Promo Code [inaudible].
All right,
we got two more here.
MVMT watches when you're in your early twenties and thirties and money can be
tight,
so it was a lot of other stuff.
Grow.
Spill.
All right.
If you're not careful,
dressing well can quickly drain your bank account.
Like spending 400 to $500 on a department store.
Watch.
Why would you do that?
There's some brands out there charging insane prices for watches that aren't
even worth it.
Well,
if you want to look great without when you go out,
but still have enough money to buy him or her a drink,
checkout movement,
watches.com all right,
these watches is shap originally founded by two broke college kids.
Um,
I'd never understand that.
They had no money and then they started a watch company with what money.
What collateral?
Um,
so you have no money and you start a watch company.
All right.
Movement watches cut out the middleman in there.
Big brand retail markups in order to give you a stylish washed watch for an
affordable price movement.
Watches start at just 95 bucks a watch with the spa department store quality for
a fraction of the price.
They're sleek and middle ballistic.
Sorry,
talking to wade through a yard here,
a modern twist on a classic style movement has grown organically purely by
supporters like you.
So join there more than 1 million social media followers and get a movement.
Watch today.
Go to M v empty watches.
That's Michael Vincent,
Michael Thomas,
watches.com/burr and they'll give you 15% off your entire purchase.
MVMT watches.com/burr and lastly,
but not leastly
stamps.com they got the quickest and the tightest fucking copy in the
advertising game.
Watch how quickly this goes.
Trips to the post office had become second nature to you.
They seem easy because you've been doing your mailing and shipping that way for
so long,
but think about all the hassle,
man.
Dropping what you're doing,
driving.
They're finding parking,
waiting.
There's a much better way.
stamps.com stamps.com is the easy and convenient way to get postage right from
your desk.
Buy and print official US postage using your own computer and printer.
They make it easy to get exact postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of mailed the instant you needed.
No expenses,
expensive postage,
meters to lease and no more trips to the post office.
She got to try it.
I use it anytime I sent out my posters and I'm a moron if I can figure out.
So can you,
so sign up for stamps.com and use my last name bar.
But this special four week trial offer a plus $110 bonus offer that includes
postage and a digital scale.
Don't not wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com and ber.
Ah Right.
Mercifully that's over.
The advertising is Hoover.
All right.
Where the fuck is the reeds for this week?
Um,
okay.
Lab grown food.
All right.
Hey Bill,
wondering if you've heard of lab grown meat.
Basically scientists to figure out a way to make plants tastes like meat.
Why aren't they fucking with the food supply?
I don't understand what they're doing.
This could eliminate our need to raise and kill millions of cows a year and help
stop the ass gas coming from these cows from continuing to ruin our planet.
I'm not sure how I feel about it,
but I liked the idea of it.
Here's an example from the article.
The impossible burger is more than just peas and carrots smashed together.
It's the result of some pretty high tech research.
Brown's team analyzes meet at a molecular level to determine what makes a burger
tastes smell and cook the way it does.
He wants his burger to be squishy while raw rouse.
Then from up and Brown on the grill,
he believes everything from an animal,
from an animal's fat tissue to muscle cells can be replicated using plant
compounds,
compounds.
Before starting the company,
Brown had a hunch that a certain ingredient made meat tastes different than
other foods.
I had a strong suspicion early on that,
okay,
I don't want to say double h.
E.
M e him would be the magic ingredient for flavor,
not hemp.
Uh,
said Brown.
Here's the link to the whole article.
Would you eat this?
Thanks.
Come back to Boston.
No,
I try not to fuck with that type of shit.
I would not eat that.
If I want meat,
I eat meat.
If I want ice cream,
I get ice cream.
I don't get low fat ice cream.
I don't try to eat ice cream.
That doesn't make me fat.
Because you're going to pay the price somehow.
All right,
and the reason why there's so many fucking cows shitting and farting into the
fucking air is cause there's so many people.
The problem,
time and time again,
there's too many fucking people.
That is the fucking problem.
So,
okay,
we all switch to these fucking plants.
Then what are we going to do then?
We're going to need all this water to grow all these fucking plants.
We are too much of a fucking burden on the natural resources of this planet.
We need to thin the fucking hurt.
That's the deal.
That's it,
everybody.
If you want a kid,
you have one,
two at the fucking most.
So,
you know,
you're not creating more people than there is you.
Right.
But that workout,
no,
that wouldn't work out because then that they both have to then you
two people and the who then go create to each.
Now it keeps getting bigger.
One Kid,
right.
Everybody has one kid,
two creates one another to meet and they create one.
That's the only way to reverse fuck our way out of this thing.
And if you never have kids,
you ought to get some sort of massive tax break.
Um,
I think that that's what you should do.
So then scientists don't have to sit around and like,
you know,
well,
at some point there's going to be no more stake.
Cause me too many fucking people,
you know,
I don't want to live on a planet with no steak,
and I would like to go back to just the way cow is just sort of ran around
chickens,
ran around and then every year,
I don't know where he just gave me all right there for it as opposed to I having
miserable lives,
you know,
I dunno.
Anyways,
let's plow ahead.
I don't know how I feel about the whole fuck.
I fucking love animals and I hate when people torture him and treat him like
shit and all that.
I also like eating them.
I love chicken.
I love steaks.
I love fish.
I like all that shit.
So like,
you know,
if we could just get somebody to get out from underneath these corporation cons
and just get everybody on the same page,
it'd be like,
look,
this is what we're doing.
Okay,
this is the problem.
This is what everybody needs to do to try to at least keep it at bay,
you know?
But there's none of that,
you know what I mean?
It's just,
just,
I don't know.
It doesn't come from the right fucking people.
All right.
Getting through college.
Fuck.
Hey mister birth.
Um,
how do I get through this college shit.
I'm currently taking anatomy and physiology one and this summer since I failed
it and it fucking blows ass.
Well,
why are you taking it?
Did you ever feel like when you were going to college,
you just couldn't do it?
Because maybe there was the,
that one class that was impossible to pass.
If so,
how did you get through it?
You know,
it's hard for me to even imagine passing this class ever getting a it.
Okay.
I didn't know what the heck.
I can't even say it.
K.
I.
N.
E s I allergy
kinesiology degree.
Sam kinesiology.
Sam Kennison degree.
Um,
thanks.
By the way.
Uh,
I saw on your Wikipedia page that you'd died and I felt horrible.
I know you don't care,
but just thought I'd tell you.
Oh,
well,
you know.
Well,
that's good.
I guess I don't have to pay taxes this year.
Um,
anyways.
Uh,
all right.
Do you ever think that you're in the wrong major?
Maybe you were in the wrong school,
like life shouldn't be that fucking heart,
dude.
It's not like you're dumb if you taking these kinds of classes.
Um,
I would say that,
um,
the turning point in my college career was when I decided that I wanted to be a
standup comedian and,
um,
I still wanted to get a college degree for whatever reason.
It was important to my parents.
And I don't know,
I just want to be a college graduate.
I don't know why I'm,
so I got out of the college I was at and I transferred to Emerson College,
which was more of a performance school and people made movies and it was acting
and radio and all of this shit.
And uh,
all of a sudden my grades went up cause I was doing shit that I was into.
Um,
but there was a couple of fucking classes that just sucked.
There's always going to be a couple of those.
How do you get through,
you know,
what you do?
Don't blow it off because if it's already hard,
you get three days behind in that thing,
it's,
it's going to be like being a month behind for you.
So what I would do is I would just stay on that shit and just be like,
all right,
plus do this.
Taking over the summers at joke,
dude,
it's practically impossible.
You know,
I was so old by the time I fucking graduated college,
didn't like Matt transferred to Emerson.
I was like,
I forget.
I was almost 23 years old and I was still just beginning my sophomore year.
I transferred there in January of whatever year,
uh,
by December of the following year,
I had done three years of college.
I just fucking,
I just,
I just said fuck this.
And I did.
I finished my sophomore year,
the January to April,
and then in the summer I picked up a semester.
So I finished that.
Then the next year was my junior year and then I went to summer school again,
picked up another semester,
and then the following fall was my second semester,
my senior year,
and that was it.
I gave it the old right there,
Fred and fucking out of here.
But what you have to do is when you go in straight through like that,
or if you're doing like the summertime shit is,
you got to stay on it.
Just treat it like a fucking job.
It's actually a good exercise.
It's something that's sucks.
It's something that you hate and you just,
you know,
rather than running from,
just turn around and face it and get through it.
If this is the degree you want,
um,
but sometimes if it's that fucking hard,
it means that you're a square peg trying to go into a round hole and he need
that
go after what you really want to fucking do.
Because you know,
when you do what you want to do,
you have a passion for it and it's,
it's easy.
Um,
Cibele that was original or whatever that they did fit that advice fit.
All right.
Would you consider a Vegas residency,
a deer country McConn face at this point in your career?
If offered,
would you accept a comedy residency in Las Vegas or would you be offended as
there's plenty of life in that old dog yet?
If not,
how bad would you,
your career have to be
okay
going before you accepted and which hotel would you like to work in next time
you come to Australia?
Play a Gig in,
uh,
Adelaide.
I Dunno,
we're not all backwards fucks.
I mean,
I,
I never thought you were take it easy.
You cunt.
Um,
what I do that well,
I couldn't,
well if I didn't have is for family or anything like that.
Um,
okay.
I don't think that that's for me.
I think my ACC would dry up if I just stayed in the same venue.
MMM.
Having said that,
the way you're,
the way you're framing that Gig as if it's a sad thing that happens to comedians
do,
those are multimillion dollar contracts.
And,
um,
anybody who's ever done one of those,
as long as they didn't go to the crap table after this show every night,
uh,
rides off into the sunset,
like with bags and bags of cash.
MMM.
That's just something that I have no interest in,
uh,
at this point in my career,
in doing,
I still like traveling and that type of stuff.
I do have to tell you though,
mmm.
If it just wasn't Vegas,
I just,
that town does nothing for me.
Just sitting there in the fucking desert.
I would go nuts.
But I do have to say that,
you know,
if I could,
yeah.
You know,
all of a sudden just get off the road.
I totally understand why comedians do that after a while.
Um,
all right.
So there you go.
All right.
And I'll,
I'll tell her you fucking town.
I'll try to get close to it next time.
All right.
Okay,
bill getting people you hate fired.
All right,
this already sounds evil.
Hey Bill,
love your shit.
I'm almost 30 mistakes are made and now I work at a shit factory.
I shovel literal shit with a pay loader.
A for about 10 hours a day,
which isn't so bad,
but it's made worse by my terrible coworkers.
It's a small operation.
Everyone is about twice my age and for the most part they are pretty average
blue collar guys.
We all had our boss and his yes man,
Aaron boy,
uh,
about Aaron boy.
He's the kind of guy who is always right.
Uh,
done his way.
Run and tell the boss what the rest of us are doing.
Rat Bastard type.
All right.
Uh,
he's also the kind of guy who says the n word to let the rest of us know.
He's a no guff taking,
no shits given type of guy.
He's not,
uh,
he's white as the driven snow and think he's Indian because he purchased a t
shirt at Walmart and with wolves on it through,
this is fucking pretty random so far.
Well,
today I took my Stan,
I snitch to human resources.
Uh,
you fucking rat bastard.
He goes,
I told them how one black employee knows Aaron boy,
a racist
to you.
You're pumped.
You have no punctuation in this.
This is Dee Dee and I,
you know,
I didn't like how in the beginning you just fucking played the victim.
Like I'm almost 30 mistakes were made and I work at a shit factory.
Like you just glossed over all your stuff and then you're saying you got
coworkers of,
well,
what about,
wait,
what about you?
You fucking awful punctuation here.
Mistakes were made.
Mistakes are continuing to be made,
sir.
All right,
let me try and get through it.
I told them how one our one black employee knows Aaron boys are racist and that
he's pissed.
I also told them about the weird sexual shit.
He says like fisting his girlfriend.
All of this is true.
And the,
the guy's a complete asshole who knows the boss won't fire him.
And he takes a complete advantage of that by making our lives.
Hell.
Is this like animal house?
It's the guy's name.
Niedermeyer.
Anyway,
I come home and smoked some weed because that's what you do when you shovel
shit.
And now I'm feeling shitty myself.
I hate the guy and I really hate my boss.
But sure enough,
human resources called me and I could sense their panic.
My money's on their fire,
on their firing him.
Everyone else at worked.
Once I'm gone and is hoping he gets fired.
But now I'm starting to feel bad and he's an asshole who I hate and I feel like
I'm sticking it to the man,
but that I go too far.
I don't,
I'm not big on rat and people out to be honest with you.
Um,
was there a way that you could have gone to him and just said,
hey,
listen,
not for nothing.
I don't want to listen to you dropping the n word.
You know,
and I don't want to listen to you talking about fist in your girlfriend.
That has nothing to do with the job.
Okay.
And then he would make your life unbelievably and,
and then I would,
I,
that's what you should've done.
You should have of come in all you guys should've just approached him,
right?
Like Mickey Rourke at the end of Pope of Greenwich Village.
Cause of my tape.
I took off a fucking dead carp.
Right?
You just come up to him and just say,
listen,
here's the deal.
Okay,
you're still our supervisor,
but no longer are you dropping the n word and no longer are you talking about
fist and your girlfriend around us.
We don't want to hear it anymore.
You understand this?
If you do,
we're going to human resources.
All right.
A fucking creepy name.
Human Resource.
So fucking disgusting.
Yeah,
that's what you should have done.
But you know,
I,
you know,
you live and you learn.
This guy sounds like a Kentucky,
you know what I mean?
Uh,
just do that in the future.
Oh.
And then you could say,
and by the way,
if you try to get any of his fire that's going down to,
so basically what we're saying is you've lost all control to intimidate us now.
Uh,
but we'll still do what you say as long as you're not a cunt.
All right?
Go Fuck Yourself.
Run off.
Uh,
why don't you do that?
You're like,
what?
I just pitched there.
That's like when the cast of friends all got together and negotiated together.
Right.
And they got their money.
You could do that at your shit factory.
All right.
Laying off the booze.
Hey Billy blunts.
After hearing you talk about drying out,
you really inspired me to do the same.
I drank entirely too much.
Right now after about eight days of daily commitment,
I'm up to about a half a fifth a day with the odd beer in a way.
And I thought you said
after about eight years of daily commitment,
I thought the eight days I thought he was like drying out and then all of a
sudden he's boosting that confused me.
Right after about eight years of daily commitment,
I'm up to about half a fifth a day and with an odd beer mixed in.
I know it's a lot,
but I've worked out my tolerance so much that I don't really get drunk anymore.
I just lose an hour here and there.
No big deal,
right?
Yeah.
The two that's called blacking out.
Anyways,
I was able to quit smoking weed after five years of heavy daily use.
No problem.
I was even able to quit using oxycotton Jesus after about three years of eating
and sniffing pills all damn day.
I've been able to maintain a normal life,
won't going through these ups and downs.
I'm married with a kid and a house and a great job.
If you make more than a million dollars,
I probably manage your retirement account,
but despite being able to put the hard shit down,
Bu's has been the hardest so far.
Last week I decided to jump off the wagon with you.
It's been hard as hell,
but I've been able to stick to it better than I ever had.
I'm trying to limit beers to two a day and only drink liquor on the weekends.
I've slipped once,
but I'm doing my fucking best.
I don't have a question.
More of a request.
Please keep us updated on your progress.
It's helping me with my own journey because none of my friends really drink at
all much less the way I do and my wife doesn't even know the extent of my issue,
which is an issue on its own.
Yeah,
it is.
Makes my struggle a bit easier to hear you having the same troubles as I have
with sticking to my resolution.
Thanks for giving me the kick in the ass.
I need to get my shit together.
All right dude.
This is what you need to do.
All right.
After just saying don't text your wife that you having a good time,
you got to let you know.
You got to let your wife know about this.
This is a major thing.
You're not sitting there eating a fucking Turkey wrap,
having a fucking bitter Mexican beer,
whatever the fuck it was called.
Um,
okay.
I would talk to her about it because then she can,
she can watch it.
Dude,
I can't fucking watch.
I can't,
I can't do this for you.
You need to have your wife involved in this and just say,
listen,
I've been drinking entirely too much and I need your help.
All right.
So,
mmm.
I gotta be honest with Dude.
I tried,
like right now I have a beer a day and that's the only,
because my wife had some people over and they left a bunch of beer in the fridge
and it's taken up all this space and I don't want to dump it down the sink,
you know,
I'm not dumping out a bunch of beers.
I just have one a day.
And what sucks is that corona lite,
which are fucking horrific.
Um,
so I don't even enjoy them.
but I just have like one a day.
Uh,
but last night it was Saturday night,
I'm home,
you know,
I got the best fucking bar in town.
I got high end booze and you know,
I had a couple of home ports,
which,
you know,
as I've mentioned before,
there's the bar poor and there's the home poor because you can lie to yourself
that you have in two scotches a night.
But you know,
when you go out to a bar and you see what their scotches are,
you like,
oh wait,
did I say too,
I meant nine.
Um,
so,
uh,
yeah,
like last night,
you know,
I had a couple,
two,
three of those after having the beer during the day and I woke up today,
I felt like I got hit by a truck,
you know,
it was awful.
I walked my dog around the block and I shook it off and I was just like,
like,
you know what it is at nighttime,
it's brutal being sober at night socks,
but being sober in the waking up the next day,
stone sober is the greatest.
It's,
it,
it feels better than getting shit faced.
Um,
so,
you know,
and my wife,
she stays on me.
She stays on me about it.
It's weird.
Like,
I don't want,
like you sound like,
you know,
you've,
you,
you've had some hardcore,
luckily I don't have like an addictive personality.
My thing is I have time,
I have free fucking time and I get into like,
and I am a creature of habit.
Like if I can't,
if I,
like,
this is how I work.
Like if I was to go out and buy a fucking pint of ice cream,
right?
And I was still wolf that fucking thing down one night,
I would start doing that.
That's what I would do.
So like if I,
you know,
and,
and all these fucking addicts who go to Aa and all this shit,
they always trying to make sure that they try to make,
like everybody's a fucking addict,
you know,
I'm not dude,
I don't have like a fucking bottle in the back of my fucking toilet and shit
sitting there shaking,
drinking fucking mouthwash and shit.
You know what I mean?
I just like drinking.
I enjoy it,
you know what I mean?
But as I get older,
like just paying for it the next day is making it not fucking worth it.
So I just don't do it.
And whenever I decide to stop,
I just stop and it sucks for a few days.
And then what it is is it's not part of my daily routine.
And then I literally just forget about it.
Um,
you know,
but I don't know,
you seem like a little bit,
uh,
beyond that.
So I would definitely reach out to you,
your wife and uh,
see if she can help you and maybe if she can help you,
you stop there and if you need more help,
I would go do that.
But,
uh,
don't depend on me because I don't have any kids and I live like a fucking 14
year old,
so I'm not a good person to a use.
I mean,
having said that,
I'm just doing a beer a day,
if that helps you.
All right.
Okay.
S t e d o g.
S t doe Jesus.
All right,
Bill Billy,
what's that red mark?
I don't know what that means.
Is that something else I need to be self conscious about?
All right.
Uh,
this is a gnarly one.
Um,
I recently found out that I have HPV,
a k,
a gentle awards,
and he then he says,
gross.
Uh,
it's actually very common and it's just a few small bumps,
but it fucking sucks anyways.
It can show up years after you've received it.
So I have no idea who I got it from.
Ah,
once again,
another great reason to get married,
to stay out of that fucking world.
Here's my question.
I recently met an amazing girl.
We have a lot of the same interests.
She's a hard 10,
Yadda,
Yadda.
Point is,
I really like her.
I'm getting treated for the HPV,
but I respect her enough to tell her of the risks.
Uh,
she's getting into,
in the case,
in case it goes that far.
So Bill,
how do I tell her that I have an STD and that there's a small chance she could
get it?
Uh,
I don't want to mess up this opportunity,
but my other options are basically to move to a cabin in the woods for six
months until this is completely gone.
Uh,
thought it'd be funny to hear your advice.
Oh,
dude.
Fuck yeah.
You gotta tell her totally 100% teller and then just don't just say,
listen,
so I can't do anything for six months other than to get to know you better.
You know?
And this is the thing,
if she doesn't want to stick around for that.
Yeah.
God bless her.
Who gives a fuck?
You know what I mean?
You've got to look at it like,
well what else wouldn't she stick around for it?
But then again,
you're also coming out of the gate saying you've got to fucking Stda.
No,
there's no right or wrong answer other than to not.
You got to tell people that shit.
You know,
don't you watch the person that had it told you you don't want it?
You don't want it.
You got to,
you got to break the chain there.
Women are so much more advanced emotionally,
so much more.
They understand love,
they understand emotions,
they understand so much more than guys do.
And it's not our fault.
It's not their fault the way that they are and all that type of shit.
It's just how we're fucking wired.
I don't fucking understand it.
Um,
it is what it is.
But uh,
you know,
if she really likes you when she's understanding and then you're sitting there
saying,
you know,
she's a hard 10,
people are trying to fuck her all the time.
So you're going to go on like,
listen is something embarrassing but it's going to be cleared up in six months
and I respect you enough to tell you,
you know,
we can hang out,
get to know each other better and all that type of stuff.
But you know,
there's no way I'm having sex with you or anybody else.
You'll come off responsible.
You'd come off as honest and if that's what the fuck she's looking for,
she'll stick around.
If she doesn't,
then fucking lay low for six months,
lay low for fucking six months and then,
you know,
whatever,
go to the gym and get fucking shredded.
No,
don't do that.
You'll get more ladies coming up to you.
Stay away.
Anyways,
let's,
uh,
let me,
let me finish off this fucking podcast.
What are we up to here?
Hour and eight minutes.
All right.
Is there anything else I wanted to talk about?
Oh,
oh,
fucking Billy red faces.
Uh,
finally going to get himself a car.
Okay.
I'm gonna order it this fucking week cause they don't have the color that I
want.
And if I'm going to buy a new car or Frugal Freddy's getting the fucking color
that he wants and I'm not going to tell you guys what kind of car that I'm
getting because I,
cause I want to enjoy the process.
I don't want to listen to,
to fuck you.
Good.
Yeah.
Would pull you fucking get this one.
You go get the one you want.
But I fucking looked at everything.
I looked at the Jaguar,
I looked at the fuck,
I looked at a BMW,
I looked at a Lexus,
I decided that I want one of those fucking four door sedans if fucking cruises.
Uh,
I found the BMW to basically be a,
you know,
I love the German like precision and the precision.
I got my kids say that precision.
There you go.
But I don't think I could speak.
Um,
you know,
you could just sit in there and you just feel the German,
all of it.
No wasted movements.
This is the punchline is stiff as he wants a comfortable ride.
You get the seven series.
Um,
I looked at Alexis,
I don't like that grill.
It looks like Darth Vader,
his mouth on his fucking helmet.
And um,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
I think I found the one though.
I literally looked at everything.
Mercedes,
BMW,
Jaguar,
Lexis,
the whole fucking thing.
You know,
I'm not getting the sick ass model.
I'm getting the one debts,
decking dead has the right and this is what,
this is what I'm going to get a four door sedan that has the biggest fucking
engine I in that I can get in it.
Right.
And,
but I'm not going to buy a high end car so I could still take it to the fucking
grocery store and when some cunt fucking OpenStep door in my car,
it's not going to kill me.
You know what I mean?
Cause I,
I don't get,
I just don't understand having a high end car like psycho high end.
Like,
I'm buying a mid range,
you know,
car Emmy.
All of them seem fucking high end to me cause I've driven a Prius for nine
fucking years.
Do you guys know I'm on my fourth car of my life.
That's all.
I've been at an 83 Ford Ranger.
Then I had this fun,
I bought a used,
I bought that used,
I drove that for fucking 10 years and then,
and then it burned down to the side of the road.
That's a long fucking story.
Then I bought a uh,
okay.
In like 96 [inaudible] 97 I bought a 1988 Honda accord.
Four to a five speed.
Fucking love that car.
And it was the top of the line,
Honda accord,
the DX,
whatever the fuck it was.
It was fun.
That was a great fucking car.
MMM.
And then I got a,
then I moved back to New York,
so I didn't need a car.
Wait a minute.
Yeah.
And then I bought my Prius and then I got the f 100.
That's all I've had.
That's pretty fucking good.
Right?
Almost 50 fucking years old had been driving since 1984.
Jesus Christ.
I'm old.
I've been driving for 32 fucking years.
I've had basically I've had three cars.
One,
two,
three,
four,
four cars.
That's pretty fucking good.
How Frugal Freddy.
So I've had enough of the Prius and had enough of it.
And you know what's funny about that car?
Cause it's a Toyota and I've changed the oil and I've maintained it and
everything.
Like there is a major part of me that wants to drive that car for the rest of my
fucking life because it's hilarious to me because I know I could get a million
miles out of that car because at the end of the day,
all these fucking dopes whose cars shit the bed unless like you remember like
the BMWs a few years ago when they were just designed to fall apart at 50 to
60,000 miles.
Um,
you know,
unless it's being done on purpose,
at the end of the fucking day,
the engine block,
it's made out of fucking steal like that.
That thing's not supposed to.
You're not supposed to have any problems with that.
That thing.
In theory,
all of that shit should last for fucking ever and granted thing here and thing
there will come loose or something like that.
But the engine itself,
when people just have the,
when your engine is just fried,
the valves of fried and all that shit,
you weren't maintained in the fucking car.
And for the life of me now when you can go to all of these fucking places,
I'm still never go to Jiffy Lube.
I still take it to the dealership.
Um,
Jiffy lube cause it's so getting in and out of there.
I always get nervous as you always hear those stories that you know,
they drain the oil out and they forget to put it back in.
Basically the poltergeist,
you know,
you move their headstones but you didn't move the bodies.
It's basically the car version of that.
Like they take the fucking oil out and you know,
whoever's supposed to put it in up top doesn't do it.
The guy down the bottom,
it's,
he just drains the fucking oil.
Right.
Then he puts the plug back in and then he's got the fucking grease gun,
he loops the chassis all up,
hits all the points.
Right?
Like he fucking knows like he even knows what model you have and where,
where they all are.
Right?
He's just fucking looking for those plugs to fill up.
Right.
And meanwhile,
some other con at the top is supposed to drop,
you know,
four,
five,
six quarts oil,
whatever it takes to the top of your engine.
And sometimes they forget,
then you drive away,
right?
And then,
then when are you going to do,
you're going to go down there and they're not going to give you your,
they're going to give you the amount of money that your car is worth,
which is the total fuck over.
Right?
Cause if it's a p,
you know,
like my car,
I,
I can't imagine what my car's worth right now.
I mean it has to be worth like maybe $1,200
but the thing is,
is for me to replace it,
the go out buy another car.
I mean I,
I can't buy a $1,200 fucking car.
You see what I'm saying?
So I was it down to the God dealership.
So anyways,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Some weeks I got diarrhea of the mouth and this is fucking one of them.
Um,
that's it for the podcast.
I'm still trying to figure out a way to bring a couple of listeners.
I decided that a contest isn't the right fucking way to do it.
Um,
I want to have a couple of podcasts,
maybe couple of two,
three podcasts.
Listeners come in for the final table read,
um,
of the year provided you don't tell everybody what happened in the script,
which could also be a fucking problem.
I think this whole idea was stupid.
I think it was a stupid idea.
You know what?
Fuck that.
Fuck it that offers off the table.
I'm sorry.
I just,
this day and age,
everybody's gonna fucking go.
Iaa won't fucking say anything.
And then you know what?
They're going,
they're going to go right away.
And what did she do after all the Yay.
Yay.
Yet bullshit.
You're going to go right fucking down.
You're going to fuck me over.
I know.
Thinks it's too much of a risk.
I'll come up with something else.
All right,
here we go.
Hour and 15 minutes.
Say you go,
you guys enjoy your Monday,
you fucking cunts and uh,
I'll check in on you on Thursday.
Uh,
I have plugged guys,
have a nice couple of days there,
right?
See Ya.